c'est pas encore tout à fait prêt mais
ce sera prêt ce soir bien entendu que
cela après ce soit toutes les équipes
sont au travail pour que les cette
exposition puisse ouvrir dans les temps
vous arrête on est dans les âmes pour là
où ça bouge c'est le festival
interstices ya beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent pour ce festival des
inclassables ckoi interstices c'est quoi
les inclassables les inclassables ce
sont des artistes qui travaillent à la
frontière de plusieurs disciplines
essentiellement le son qui reste la
trame du festival même si c'est un
festival d'arts visuels
il ya une dizaine de lieux qui sont
partenaires de l'événement
l'artothèque l'église du vieux saint
sauveur le musée de caen le château de
caen la salle de l'échiquier les âmes
le dôme cargo le pavillon le café des
images voilà on y est je crois on va où
là là on va la mairie qui m'attend
s'appelle le dos
nous voilà dans le dôme avec une oeuvre
très particulière qui émet un son
étonnant c'est une composition
absolument une composition de 40 minutes
c'est une composition qui est fait à
partir de larsen donc un principe de
boucles entre un micro et un
haut-parleur comme mode de les gens qui
jouent de la guitare électrique passe
devant leurs amplis et là c'est tout à
fait maîtrisée sacré des harmonicas ces
belles c'est une forme d'orgue à
marseille
avec des enceintes qui monte qui descend
voilà qui crée des variations des notes
en fonction de leur hauteur la largeur
des tubes et de la route distances avec
le microphone quel est l'artiste
il s'appelle irun 22 sound et viennent
de belgique mais on peut le voir
gratuitement tout est gratuit
absolument tous les spectacles et
performances les expositions absolument
tout alors ici c'est de quelle heure à
quelle heure c'est du mardi au samedi de
15 heures à 19 heures vous savez tout
là où ça bouge au théâtre du préau de
vire pour vous parler du festival à dos
7e édition ce sont des rencontres mais
aussi des spectacles fait pour eux
parfois par eu plein de choses à voir à
écouter à découvrir c'est jusqu'au 18
mai et ça commence ce soir avec une
création intitulée spasmes balle tu peux
venir son mec
maintenant cette barre puis de toute
façon tu écoutes pas quand on parle moi
j'écoute pas moi j'écoute pas et vilaine
avec toi papoulais d'amour se passe
c'est à la fois interne de vie et puis
un terme de mort alors de quoi on parle
dans cette pièce de ça c'est ça on parle
de la vie et de la mort
on parle de comment comment rester en
vie quand la mort surgit et dans une
famille par exemple en l'occurrence et
et on parle du deuil en fait c'est une
famille qui doit faire le deuil après la
mort de la grande soeur qui se fait
écrabouiller par un chauffard et sait
comment dans cette famille là bas
comment ils chacun retrouve sa place une
nouvelle place puisqu'il ya un élément
qui disparaît et comment la vie va
ressurgir au milieu de tout ça trois
jeunes virois chantent dansent jouent
dans la pièce de solenzo ni encadré par
les acteurs professionnels du collectif
denis dyack
il vaut mieux percer dans l'est
regardez
encore plus noir
perdu dans la danse
ce sont des élèves qui sont en option
lourde de théâtre qui font huit heures
me semble-t-il de théâtre par semaine
elise on en fait vite par jour en fait
la liste des huit pages donc ils ont
vraiment on a vraiment vu la
transformation chez eux spasmes donc à
découvrir dès ce soir à l'ouverture de
ce festival
et puis après ça dure jusqu'à jusqu'à
samedi jusqu'au 38,6 au préau mai et
après on fait une tournée dans le bocage
dans la foulée de village en village
pas facile de capter les ados c'est faux
depuis sept ans à vivre ça fonctionne on
essaie constamment de dire à travers ce
festival notamment que le théâtre est un
art qui s'adresse à eux qui s'adresse à
eux jeunes d'aujourd'hui du monde dans
lequel il n'aurait qu'une entente dans
lequel ils vivent
et c'est vrai que commencer le plus tôt
possible avec des thématiques qui
peut-être les les concernent davantage
on peut espérer que ces gens là vont
progressivement aller au théâtre
naturellement parce qu'ils considéreront
que c'est un endroit où on parle d'eux
il en restera toujours quelque chose
merci de nous avoir reçu pour cette 7e
édition du festival de quatre ados
demain nous parlerons du travail des
collégiens vi roi du val de vire qui se
sont attaqués à un grand classique de la
tragédie grecque
n'oubliez pas le festival danses de tous
les sens qui se tient jusqu'à samedi à
falaise cette année le thème décliné par
les chorégraphes s'intitule matières
premières tout programme de ces 14e
rencontres chorégraphiques et sûr dans
tous les sens poids comme à demain